c'est ça j'ai tellement hâte et revoir
mesdames et messieurs j'ai le plaisir de
vous présenter ce soir ma plus grande
découverte
le papyrus de midas si le collier n'est
pas qu'une légende alors le pouvoir de
midas celui qui le détient peut vraiment
transformer en or tout ce qu'il touche
[Applaudissements]
j'arrive fera date stone ça votre
service
oh non non non non non tu ne viens pas
avec moi si non c'est non
je suis fier donnez-moi le carnet où
c'est la dernière fois que vous la voyez
[Musique]
j'ai beaucoup mûri rechargeable n'avons
rien fait déjà mauricio faux
dégage un truc tu n'as fait comment ce
stade est le secret du roi midas oh
désolé je fais toujours ça quand je suis
pas vraiment aucun amour propre au
cinéma le 16 mai
[Musique]